william and kate's caribbean tour has
been full of good times but behind the
scenes oh no no they are trying to
manage a royal mess boy welcome to
entertainment tonight you know they're
actually on this trip in honor of the
queen's platinum jubilee but it seems
the celebration's over
it's suddenly been a challenging tour
there were some cute moments soccer in
jamaica and trying out a bobsled but six
days into their eight-day caribbean tour
newsweek is calling it a royal disaster
the couple facing protests and thrust
into a debate about removing the queen
as head of state amidst tensions
surrounding britain's history of slave
trade slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
this photo is also sparking a backlash
it was snapped tuesday and shows will
and kate shaking hands with people
through a fence the cropped image looked
terrible
while william and kate tackle that pr
crisis there's news today about meghan
markle's podcast debut this morning
spotify released a one-minute audio
teaser i'm megan and this is archetypes
the podcast where we dissect explore and
subvert the labels that try to hold
women back
megan's series is expected to launch
this summer the duke and duchess of
sussex reportedly signed a 25 million
deal with the streaming platform royal
watcher katie nichols says expect some
famous names you can bet your bottom
dollar that we'll have oprah will have
ellen and there's a new twist today in
the royal rift between will and harry a
source tells e.t relationships remain
complicated between the once inseparable
brothers e.t has learned prince harry
will not return to the uk next week for
an event honoring his grandfather prince
philip meanwhile prince william turns 40
in june and harry well he probably
shouldn't expect a party invite the idea
that everything's going to be fine and
he's going to have harry at his 40th
birthday is is simply not going to
happen it's very obvious that this is
now a distant relationship there is an
ocean between them there is a lot of
unresolved issues and it's i think it's
simply not the case that we're going to
see happy family reunions